so we looked at this wall street journal
article about the declining college
rates for men have you seen this
floating around
no dude this is going on this article is
[ __ ] scary so i've known this for
quite a while but it's really just
starting to hit mainstream media and one
of the reasons that it's probably not
too popular amongst mainstream media is
that it goes counter to a narrative that
men are outperforming women and there's
this oppressive patriarchal construct
that's misogynistically trying to keep
people down blah blah blah are people
still on that are people still on that
massively massively so okay the number
of men enrolled at two and four-year
colleges has fallen behind women by
record levels in a widening education
gap across the u.s men are abandoning
higher education in such numbers that
they will now trail female college
students by record levels at the close
of the 2020 2021 academic year women
made up 59.5 of college students an
all-time high in men 40.5
according to enrollment data from the
national student clearinghouse and
nonprofit research group in the us
colleges and universities had 1.5
million fewer students compared with
five years ago and men accounted for 71
of that decline in the next few years
two women will earn a college degree for
every man american colleges have yet to
reach a consensus on what might slow the
retreat of men from higher education
i think people are
this could go a number of ways this
discussion and i this is actually this
is
critical to where we are
you know in society as a whole
how valuable
is
an education and what about
being a man
would would provide a man to say this
isn't as valuable you know as opposed to
a woman
what about their psychology
is saying that or allowing that to
happen and then also
in what way will the media suppress this
you know
the narrative is so i'm not convinced
that the media can really suppress the
stats like you can in within 10 years as
you walk around on campus you're going
to see double the number of women as you
do men i don't know the equivalent for
the uk but in the us that's going to be
the case like there's it's not about
suppressing the stats like there is no
suppressing that
some of the reasons that you could put
forward for why this may have occurred
is that there has been quite a negative
environment for men generally in the
universities um
quite rightly women have had to have
their spaces be made to feel better the
metoo movement was like [ __ ] long
overdue to call powerful men to account
for taking advantage of women
um
but what it's done is it's taken quite a
broad brush and applied that to all men
when the research suggests that it's a
small minority of men that commit almost
all of the sexual offences this is what
david bust discovered uh evolutionary
psychologists that i had on the show
that the vast majority of men aren't
sexual predators but a small number of
men commit [ __ ] tons of acts but if
you tar everybody with a quite a broad
brush if you make it a little bit of a
hostile environment in which men feel
quite uncomfortable then that's not so
good you've also got like the equivalent
of affirmative affirmative action
programs that promote girls success
within high school and within college
applications i'm not sure if you have
outright sort of gendered discrimination
when it comes to accepting into courses
i would imagine no
but
i think it's significantly harder for
boys to get through school if you are
someone that's more physically minded if
you're someone who's got adhd but
previously there was so much prestige
and status associated with an education
that you would be able to you would be
prepared to go through that there's a
lot of discomfort associated with me
sitting on my ass and [ __ ] having to
learn all of this stuff and i want to be
outside playing or play fighting or
building something or doing whatever but
i'll get through it because the college
is going to be worth it and um
yeah now two to one females to males
within the next 10 years
that is crazy two to one yeah at every
college here's the thing um and i think
i might have talked about this on the
the last podcast that i did with you a
year and a half ago but
colleges in america and for those who
are listening in the uk and the rest of
the world colleges in america are unlike
anything you've ever [ __ ] seen before
what do you mean and all you have to do
is go to a collegiate football game to
understand exactly what i'm saying they
make millions of dollars off ticket
sales per game
they
make
over you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars
from
anything from like selling apparel to
food
tv rights millions of dollars
uh
all of this in
as a way you know think about it like
countries that what they do for the
olympics to kind of flex their prowess
without actually having to go to war
this is what colleges are doing
and it's a prestige
yes
yes and it is a war it is an all-out
[ __ ] war and there's a
conference called the sec which is the
southeast conference and that one is the
most powerful one
uh as far as money
it's ridiculous what's this got to do
with men and women in college
well it's it's basically the importance
of college isn't what we think it is
there's so much of it is like we have so
so i can speak from uh a perspective of
someone who lived in an area college
station where texas a m is there are 60
000 undergrads 60 000 people at a school
that is ridiculous the amount of money
that goes into that school
how much prestige is there really when
there's 60 000 other people doing the
same thing you are now mind you some of
them are engineers some of them are
medical students
trying to get law degrees that's a
different
you know all together
but what we have is this massive money
making industry trying to
coax people to get into these colleges
and go to college and maybe take on debt
when the reality is there's not much
prestige anymore
and maybe there never really was
but it's kind of starting to be away
maybe i don't know so you saying that
girls that men have seen the the light
and taken the red pill in in college and
girls have still got the whirlpool done
in their eyes maybe honestly because
think about how
think think about how men interact with
the internet
and how it may be different with the way
women do
you know if
you know and this is again this is we're
talking through it here this one
i think that you you're actually onto
something here and the reason that i do
is that for a long time women were told
the culture
and the powers that be told women you
have been oppressed for a very long time
um the only reason that you're able to
get a job is that you've got to fight
your way up there this is something that
you shouldn't deserve the only way that
you're able to get an education is
because you've had to so what that does
is the the the subtext to a lot of
females is
i
the only way that i can get this is if i
really deserve it it puts it on a
pedestal it adds prestige to college
fake prestige that now like when it's
when you're talking 59 to to 40 of 60 40
basically in terms of the ratio like
it's obvious that it's not as difficult
for girls to get into college anymore
but because you have this sort of
lagging measure that all of these sort
of tradition traditions in terms of
culture that people have still got that
in their mind a lot of girls may still
have the idea that i shouldn't be
allowed to go to college it still is
something of prestige this is me
standing out
i think that there's something to that
yeah so they're they're they're coming
from us a place of like
not vengeance but
this this motivation
yeah that they're behind and this is
their way to be in front yeah that's
that's definitely possible
you know it's going to be multifaceted
it's going to be something that is
encouraging girls to go it's going to be
something which is discouraging guys to
go so here's the [ __ ] here's the
implication man so david burst
father of evolutionary psychology he
wrote in 2015 he wrote about the
the challenges you have when you have an
asymmetry in terms of education between
men and women okay this is something
that you said quote we must look deeply
into our mating psychology to understand
the far-reaching consequences of the sex
ratio imbalance so that is when you have
a disproportionate number of one sex to
another uh in an area women and men have
both evolved multiple mating strategies
some of the gender pursue casual hookups
some committed partnerships some
alternate at different times of their
lives and some do both simultaneously
and although
a few social scientists deny the data
research overwhelmingly shows that men
harbor on average a greater desire for
sexual partner variety shock
men experience more frequent sexual
thoughts throughout the day have more
sexual fantasies involving multiple
partners and readily sign up for online
dating sites for the sole goal of casual
sex so a surplus of women among educated
groups caters precisely to this
dimension of men's sexual desires
because the rare agenda is always better
positioned to get what they want on the
mating market so what you see in
colleges where there is a surplus of
women and a scarcity of men is more
casual dating because the men get to
make the rules if there are fewer men
than there are women the women have to
compete and the only way that they can
compete is by playing the game that the
men want conversely
in a college where you have more men
than you do women you have more
long-term relationships because the men
have to play the game that the women
want
a surplus of women amongst educated
groups caters precisely to this
dimension of men's sexual desires
because the rare agenda is always better
positioned to get what they want on the
mating market
roll it forward a little bit you now
have two-thirds to one-third educated
women to educated men on the whole women
don't want to date a man that is less
educated less rich and lower status than
them and also one that's shorter than
them you are going to have an
ever-increasing group of women competing
for an ever decreasing group of high
performing men the men that sit below
them don't get don't don't win anything
so that there's more in cells there's
more underperforming men white collar
women don't want to date blue collar
blue collar guys
and
most of the women even the ones that
went to college
they're now competing for this tight
group of chads at the [ __ ] super
performing rowing chads at the top and
the only ones that win are these [ __ ]
turbo weapons the 9 out of 10 and 10 out
of 10 guys that have got mbas the ones
who are able to outperform
intellectually socially and uh
monetarily the women they're the only
ones that are left that are able to date
so nobody wins except for chad
chad wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
why does it always have to be okay but i
was if it's two to one all you have to
do is make it into college and you've
got two to one odds baby that's it
that's not hard go to tech getting into
texas a m is not hard you and i could
right now take whatever test necessary
and get into texas a m sorry i apologize
to anyone that's actually that's
probably not true i think it's actually
a pretty prestigious school
let's say like because you live there
and you don't want to be you'd only be
berated by them on the street no
okay let's let's do louisiana stuff i've
heard from i've heard from people lsu
you just have to sign your name on a few
tests and they'll let you in that's what
i've heard from from from people who
have gone to lsu mind you i'm not not
this is okay so
what i got from this and i why i was
smiling while you were talking and i
didn't want to interrupt but i did at
some point
was all you have to do then in 10 years
from now is just go to college and the
babes are gonna come at you here's one
for you man the difference in right
swipes on tinder for a guy with a
master's degree versus a bachelor's
degree is
i want to say 90 more
so you get 90 percent
90 more right swipes if you've got a
master's degree versus a bachelor's
degree on tinder this is in john burgess
anyone that wants to fact check me this
is in john burge's date and omics
i i honest to god i'll tell you right
now i don't understand women
i
i just not in not in the sense of like
oh i don't understand them they're
stupid it's like no no like i literally
thought that i might have an inkling of
an understanding of what it was ninety
percent what a woman thinks
i don't stick about for one year so if
you've got your bachelor's degree and
you think do i want to stick about and
do this masters that look man it's a
year of your life it's going to be a bit
expensive you're going to have to work
hard but dude 90 better conversions on
tinder for the rest of your life that's
what this should put on the enrollment
thing [ __ ] the course doesn't matter
about the course you get to have 90
better conversions on tinder dude if
if like uh all that these schools need
to do or start making snarky comments on
tick tock and then promoting their
programs
and and promoting their programs with um
with stats like that
hey if you enroll now there's a nut and
you end up graduating our course there's
a 90 chance that you will get more
swipes than someone who does it come on
in i'd go
i would probably
i did i did get a masters i did not for
that reason but
it worked out
yeah [ __ ] man yeah it's a mess it's a
it's a real [ __ ] mess and um
who knew
who knew that you're going to have all
of these hyper-educated hyper-rich babes
walking around just
dry as the desert not able to get any
you know is that is it sucks for
everyone it even sucks it sucks for
women sucks for men the only people that
win are the high performing man
but it's not high performing to get into
college if it's two to one girls no so
it's women want a date up and across so
it wouldn't just be a guy with a college
degree it's usually equal or above
state education so if you if [ __ ] if
it if this continues to happen and you
have women getting like masters level
education at some insane rate the guys
that want
if they do want to sort of play that
game they're going to have to continue
to
[ __ ] know what you're saying play
catch up because women women are the
sexual gatekeepers so they always
determine the minimum level that it goes
at the difference is obviously when
you're on a college campus that's got a
surplus of girls or anywhere so i think
new york city has far more women than
guys and you see the same thing there
that women adopt more male
uh
dating strategies because they need to
play the game that men are playing
yeah
[ __ ] it's
it's very very [ __ ] thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace